[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
not only do computers read code
you also read code
a lot
most of the time actually
in fact uncle bob says that the ratio of
time spent reading versus writing is
well over 10
to 1. we are constantly reading all code
as part of the effort to write new code
but a lot of the time you look like that
you can't understand what i tried to do
programming is hard
inherently just as the way it is
but i make it harder by writing code
that's hard for you to read
luckily this is treatable
hi and welcome to my clinic my name is
moran weber i'm the ceo and founder of
women on stage women on stage is a
global community platform to showcase
book and train women professional tech
speakers for any event conference meetup
or webinar in my previous background i
have 10 years of experience working as a
software developer and other than that
i'm also a social psychologist
obviously i don't practice it for a
living but i do have a master's degree
in social psychology
and i'm here today to talk about how
each and every one of you can use
cognitive psychology
in order to write to better understand
how we read and interpret code and as a
result take
take away a few scientifically backed
techniques on how to write code that is
more readable
so
what makes code readable
readability is all about conveying
intent and making that intent clear
to others
and to your future self
have you ever looked at a piece of code
and thought to yourself what the hell
only to discover a few moments later
when you annotate that you were the one
who wrote it a few years back
me too
so let us start our journey by speaking
about how to make your intent clear to
others and to your future self
so let's play a little game
i'm going to show you a list of words on
screen and what i want you to do is to
shout out to see the words
and to shout out their colors and not
the word itself okay the color of the
word and not the word itself don't worry
let's do a little test together remember
say the color of the word and not the
word itself all of us together
green
blue green
yellow blue
blue
red yellow red green did you get it did
you get the hang of it okay are you
ready for the real thing
okay
green blue red green yellow blue green
green red blue
red yellow blue blue
[Laughter]
did you feel it did you feel the pain
this game is called the stroop task this
troop task became a tool for american
intelligence officials during the cold
war a covert agent could claim not to
speak russian but it take longer to to
to recognize the russian words for color
this is because
we excel at reading and processing text
we're so good at it that we cannot turn
this feature off
when we see text we read it
and we infer meaning
that meaning creates expectations
when the colors doesn't match that
expectations
it hurts
the names we give our functions and
variables create expectations as well
when
when the values doesn't doesn't match
those expectations it can hurt just as
much
so that's why good names are all about
creating expectations
and fulfilling them
what do we expect the variable is
readable to be i'd expect it to be a
boolean
and not a string false
and what about collection size
i'd expect it to be sorry i'd expected
to be a a number and nothing else but of
course none of you would write code like
that of course
of course not
but maybe
maybe
you've seen something like this what do
you expect file names to be a list of
file names obviously
but wait
do they include the relative paths
when i debug it and i see what the
variable is holding it kind of makes
sense to me the name it kind of makes
sense to me
but if instead of asking yourself does
the name make sense or not ask yourself
what will the next reader what will the
next developer expect to see
it's easier for me to understand that i
probably need a different name
good name is unambiguous and probably
creates expectations into a reader's
mind so
when i was still when i was working at
wix a few years ago i found a a weird
bug in one of our blog components and it
got me to look at the is ready method so
what do you expect is ready to return
obviously you expect it to return a
boolean which it did
but the thing that really surprised me
is that the bug was introduced because
of an http post message that was being
sent out from inside the israeli method
and it really surprised me so the and i
want to be clear here that this is good
code this code served millions
millions of users on a daily basis so
the first thing i did other than fix the
bug after i found it is to make sure
that no other developer will experience
the same surprises as i did and to be
clear and to create the proper
expectations for the next reader so i
renamed the function to is ready with
side effects
and i want to be clear that this happens
everywhere even in popular front-end
frameworks like angularjs let me quote
this question from stackoverflow
what are the differences between a
service a provider
and a factory in angularjs it has more
than 3000 app votes and almost 2 000
stars it has been viewed almost 800 000
times over the last nine years
think about those numbers think about
how many developers were struggling with
the same question because the naming
because it did it failed to create the
proper expectations
to sum this section up i would say don't
think about when when you name when
you're naming a variable or a function
don't think about does it make sense or
not retroactively ask yourself
what will the next developer expect to
read
and
fulfill those expectations
okay so
let us play another game
some of you might remember the famous
simon game from the 80s
and for those of you don't don't worry
it's pretty simple
you're going to see what i'm going to
show you is a list of colors on screen
so what you need to do is to see the
colors
remember them and after that shout them
out loud don't worry you'll get the
point
so let's do a little trial first
first min then you red green yellow blue
okay
let's try the next one
red green yellow blue green blue blue
blue red yellow red
[Laughter]
very nice
so what i wanted to show you with this
game is that our memory capacity is
limited there's only so many colors we
can remember
this has been called in psychology our
working memory or our short-term memory
you can think of it as our ram so our
ram capacity is limited
in fact research has shown that most
people can store in their working memory
an average number of between five to
nine items on any given times this has
been introduced as the magical number
seven plus minus two
but what if we want to remember more how
can we hack the limits of our memory
luckily we can do so by using chunking
chunking basically means taking long
pieces of information and dividing them
up into smaller meaningful parts or
units
so let's see a little example of that
um okay imagine you had this long list
of colors from the simon game before
take a few seconds and try to to
memorize the entire list
please raise your hand if you can recall
the entire list without making any
mistakes
amazing
okay so let's try it with chunky
rugby
burger
rugby burger
now raise your hand if you can recall
the entire list
great
so and let's see another example of
chunking say i would ask you to to
remember this entire array of 16
characters it's really hard
at first glance but by using chunking
and dividing them up into smaller
meaningful words now it's so much easier
to do so and i want to to emphasize that
for a computer
in both cases the storage it probably
needs the same amount of storage but for
human beings the second example is so
much easier
and i bet you probably think to yourself
well okay so all of your examples are
well engineered and what does it have to
do with code in real life examples
so i'm glad you asked and let's see a
little example of chunking with code
say you had a function that does a hotel
reservation and it gets all of these
parameters
so at first glance when i read it it's
really hard to keep track it feels like
okay it stacks overflow my mind and by
the time i get to the end of the
function i can't remember where where i
started i and obviously all of these
parameters i'm are mandatory i can't do
the function without them
but if i use chunking and i divide them
into smaller meaningful objects or
namespaces
now it's so much easier to to to read
the signature of the function
and let's see another example say you
had the the func the make reservation
function from before would look like
that please don't read it it's long on
purpose
but once again when i read it it's
really hard to keep track and it's
really when and when i say it's hard to
remember i don't mean that it i i need
to remember it in a month from now i
mean that while i read it as i read it
it's hard to remember
by the time i get to the end of the
function i can't even remember where i
started so if i use chunking and i
divide them into smaller meaningful
functions
now it's so much easier to understand
the bigger picture and to understand the
story this function is telling me and
it's also so much easier to to debug
because if i know there's a bug in one
specific line i only need to step into
that specific line i don't need to debug
the whole thing
and let's see one last example of
chunking
say you had this function
on a first glance i bet if i give you
some more time you probably figure out
what it does but once again on first
glance it's really hard to understand
it looks this one liner looks like
minified code
but if i use chunking into smaller
meaningful steps and i named and i named
the variables accordingly now it's so
much easier to understand what is
what is written here and i and i can see
that the function is doing
is taking the first red last green first
blue last yellow and then concatenate
them all so i understand that this
function is chunking by colors
to sum this section up
try to think about which parts of your
code can be easily chunked together into
smaller meaningful
objects
namespaces arguments
functions and separate steps
okay
i want to ask you something
how many how many of you are currently
aware
of the the sensation of clothes on your
body
how many of you are currently aware
of the sensation of the pressure of the
chair against your back
how many of you are currently aware of
the sound the air conditioning is making
these all
somehow magically disappear until we're
being reminded of them
that's our amazing filtering um
mechanism that's our mind amazing
filtering mechanism in action
all day long all day long our senses are
constantly being bombarded by sound
light temperature smells
that's why our minds are masterpieces
masterpieces in processing and filtering
out data
the thing is is that
if your mind can predict the noise it
can easily filter it out
daniel kahaneman a nobel prize winner
for the realm of human decision making
describes two modes of thinking
system one is fast it's instinctive is
the more emotional part of the brain
and system two is slower it's more
deliberate it's the more logical part of
the brain
system one is the one that does the
filtering out
have you ever driven your car to work
only to discover when you get there that
you can't remember the drive
this is where it has acute name this is
called the the highway hypnosis it's
when um system one had automated the the
mundane task of driving so system two
can focus on what's really important
which is the podcast you listen to
or the project you have at work or what
you're going to have for dinner
when system 1 doesn't know what to do it
interrupts system 2 immediately
when we keep noticing inconsistent
coding styles line breaks um
one single versus double quotes
um
it's um
some missing semicolons it's like system
one is saying hey hey i don't know what
to do here let's play it safe let's ask
system two
having your code style consistent is
just like driving a long straight road
it doesn't grab your attention and you
can focus on what's really important
which is the business logic itself
but i bet you probably think well yeah
we have linters for that and we have
automatic formatters to do all of that
we don't need to to worry about it but
it's more than that and there are stuff
that linters just can't solve like
naming
for instance if you have similar actions
and you use different names for the same
action or similar actions it's so much
easier for c
versus
using the same word for similar actions
it's so much easier for system
for system one to do the filtering out
and you can focus on what's really
important which is the differences
between the functions
system one is a superpower
it can instantly locate the source of
sound when someone calls your name
it can complete well-known phrases like
my name is inodya montoya you killed my
father
it can read a text out of the billboard
it can drive a car on a long empty road
and so much more just as long as you are
predictable
so i say let system 1 do its job write
predictable code and make filtering easy
again
but sometimes um those interrupts can
can be useful for instance when there's
a child who runs into the into the road
you want to be able to stop your car
immediately and we can use that in order
to put warning signs into our code
for instance we can say
hey hey don't use me i'm deprecated
or we can say i know functions should do
only one thing and to do it well i do
two thing two things pay attention
or you can use the israeli with side
effects that i that i showed that i that
i showed you before
so to sum this section up i would ask i
would say
write predictable code and make
filtering easy again
so we've discussed how to properly
create expectations and fulfilling them
into our readers minds we talked about
how we can
easily chunk our
our our code together into smaller
meaningful parts and we we talked about
writing predictable code but there's one
inherent problem with all of these
and that there that is all subjective
so the problem is that
um the only way the only way to actually
verify that your intent is clear that
that your code was readable is by doing
a code review and if there's one thing i
want you to take away from my talk today
and one thing alone is that you need a
code review doesn't matter how skilled
you are doesn't matter how many years of
experience you are
everybody need a code review and if you
don't believe me
i hope i'll show you it soon
so
let's play another game i want you to
raise your hand when you spot the man's
face okay
do you want me to tell you okay
so if you didn't see it it's right there
[Laughter]
but now that you've seen it
you can't unsee it
it just pops out you can't understand
how you couldn't see it in the first
place
it's the same thing with your code
since you are the one who wrote it it's
clear to you you you already know your
intent you were the one who wrote it but
the problem is is that others only see a
bunch of coffee beans
let us play so sorry so the only way the
only way to verify your intent is clear
is with a code review
another game okay and this time it's a
competition
um let's test how good you are you'd be
surprised to see how many failed this
and if you already know this pl know
this game please don't ruin it for
others okay
so i'm going to show you a video and i
want you to count how many times the
player is wearing white and only the
player is wearing white past the
basketball
okay
this is a test of selective attention
count how many times the players wearing
white pass the basketball
how many passes did you count
the correct answer is 15 passes
but did you see the gorilla
[Music]
this video is from research by daniel
simons and christopher sabri and is
copyrighted
it is available for use in talk
this is
when you tell me where to focus
that is all i see
when you ask me for a code review and
then explain to me your code it's like
you're telling me to count passes
i won't be able to see the gorillas in
your code i won't be able to see the
bugs in your code i won't be able to see
the design flaws and worst of all you
won't know if your code is readable or
not
that's why code reviews should always be
called cold code reviews and by cold i
mean don't give me an intro don't tell
me what you did or explain your design
just sent out a pull request and the
reviewer will look on their own
code review is a dish best served code
okay
so let's see what you learned this is
the last game i promise uh once again
it's a compute it's a competition i'm
going to show you a video and what i
want you to do to see it is to count how
many times the plarens wearing white
pass the basketball
the monkey business illusion
count how many times the players wearing
white past the ball
the correct answer is 16 passes
did you spot the gorilla
for people who haven't seen or heard
about a video like this before about
half missed the gorilla
if you knew about the gorilla you
probably saw it but did you notice the
curtain changing color or the player on
the black team leaving the game
let's rewind and watch it again
here comes the gorilla and there goes a
player and the curtain is changing from
red to gold
when you're looking for a gorilla you
often miss other unexpected events
and that's the monkey business illusion
learn more about this illusion and the
original gorilla experiment at the
invisiblegorilla.com
did you see the gorilla
did you see the curtain changing its
color
did you see the player on the black team
leaving the team
you need a code review
on a more personal note
i would like to share with you the fact
that i used to hide the fact that i also
studied psychology
other than computer science it was
because in one of the first interviews i
had when i just finished school an
interviewer laughed at me about it and
claimed i was wasting his time because
of it
i always thought a developer should be
like this cold ninja
robot fella and if i'm the kind of
person who understands how people think
act analyze and behave perhaps i should
just keep it to myself
but now i know that knowing these
patterns and using them in predicting in
predicting actually makes me a better
coder
a better reviewer and a much better
engineer
and that's because
any fool can write code that a computer
can understand
good programmers write code that humans
thank you
you